[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
هو
[موسيقى]
[ضحك
] أحتاج إلى شخص ما لسماع شخص ما ليعرف
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
الآن
[الموسيقى]
كنت
قدمي
[الموسيقى]
الآن اليوم
[ضحك  ]
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
حب
[موسيقى]
قال أحدهم إن لديك صديقًا جديدًا ،
هل يحبك أكثر مما أستطيع ،
لا أعرف أين
أنت بنفسي أنا في الزاوية
أشاهدك وأنت تحبها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] وأنا هنا
] وأظل
وحيدًا أريد فقط أن أرقص طوال الليل
[موسيقى]
أنا أدور
لماذا لا أستطيع
[  الموسيقى
] أستمر في الرقص
بمفردي بعيدًا ولكن ما زلت
عزيزة
على الأكاذيب ماتت
[موسيقى]
لذا من
الأفضل أن نفعل
[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
هناك وقت أتذكر فيه عندما
لم أرغب في الألم
عندما  لقد آمنت بذلك إلى الأبد
وسيظل كل شيء على حاله
الآن أشعر بقلبي وكأنه شهر ديسمبر عندما يحب
شخص ما
[موسيقى]
الآن
أحيانًا ما يحب الجميع في يوم من الأيام
[الموسيقى]
ولكن كل شيء سيكون على ما
يرام  للذين حصلنا على هتافات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ذكرياتك